[Applaudissements]
à l'origine bien voilà il y aura
d'autres motards d'or demain je sais que
vous aimez ça les chéris on a vu on a vu
qu'ils traitaient jean michel maire de
mythos et bien jean michel maire il nous
a dit il ya un instant qu'ils avaient la
cote avec anggun et bien on a le numéro
dans goon on va l'appeler tout de suite
la jante est grisé et on va bien voir
allez c'est parti mais on appelle en
drones ça y est là vous entendez quand
une sonnerie retentit ça veut dire qu'on
a d'être la personne du fils dans
quelques instants à la halle aux goudes
oui c'est cyril hanouna ma chérie
comment ça va ça va ça va au goût ne te
dérange ma chérie nasa va chez avec ma
fille qui est alors je vais te dire ce
qu'il y a on est en direct à la
télévision la chaîne touche pas à mon
pote tu connais un petit peu d'émissions
mais louis quand même à temps ça va ça
va ma chérie parce que tu as ouvert avec
moi aussi à la radio on est on est très
amis et qu'on goût de la belle isle en
terre
anggun j'ai un gros problème c'est que
y'a un mec dans touche pas à mon poste
qui dit qu'il a la cote avec toi a pas
bon tu sais qui alors on good je vais te
dire c'est jean michel maire qui nous a
dit qu'il avait chauffé à mort dans
l'émission quand tu étais venu à maurice
ou
alors pourquoi joe a mais je crois qu'il
n'a pas digéré le villoux bah oui parce
qu'ils devront vous embrasser
l'embrasser qu'est ce qu'elle vous a dit
que vous avez dit quelque chose tout à
l'heure on ne sait jamais mais tu l'as
tuée je crois me souvenir c'est vrai
qu'on avait fait un gag enfin gag
malheureusement j'ai été la victime
julien tu avait remplacé pour me faire
la bise ou armées d'haïti ma vie dit on
est à l'antenne mon mari regarde mais
j'aurais vraiment kiffé t'embrasser
vraiment parce que c'est vrai que pacte
qui m'excite bitume à bin issa de façon
plus romantiques genre vous trouve très
beau jour d'autres mais d'équipé témoin
[Rires]
merci
angulo dit être en bonne intitulé oui
est ce qu'il vous plaît jean michel
maire dit la vérité ou pas dire non on
pourrait dire oui ça pour vous préférez
que j'ai dit non vous pouvez la vérité
oui on veut la vérité en bonne et on
veut la vérité la vérité c'est qu'on a
c'est à dire que oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est fait
c
ouais ouais non alors aux hormones on
passe ou naturelle à cautionner passer
pour des cons pendant la botte de vol à
la majeure partie de la phrase en bas
merci au goût de ses prêts ce que vous
aviez ce que vous venez de dire quelle
partie quand vous avez dit qu'il vous
plaisait non non je préfère quand même
un homme qui tombe plus aux actifs
risqués jeu des jeunes et sept jeunes et
aux gones
on comprend pas elle est l'oeuvre je
tombe bien son goût de tomates cherry je
t'embrasse très fort merci en goguette
avec le cas nouvel album sur mes gardes
opus on dit j'adore version angoulême
[Applaudissements]